i think early founders will be better
off thinking about security earlier than
later
because it does become a blocker
and the blocker becomes when for example
they try to do a poc for one of the
fortune 500 companies
and then they get a huge security
questionnaire that they have you know
they're having a hard time understanding
where to start right
i think early founders should put more
security budget more consciousness about
their security because it is a blocker
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we
have with us leo klisman co-founder of
sentent
leo is an entrepreneur hart co-founder
of sentinet a successful and unique i.t
security and compliance firm for
startups and emerging businesses he
takes great pride in his achievements
working with and advising hundreds of
expanding companies with sensitive
compliance requirements through their
journey of explosive growth to
acquisition the sentiment team supports
their clients with everything from cloud
and application security to day-to-day
iot operations lior is a lifelong
technology nerd specializing in
automation infrastructures and physical
security systems
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders all the way
from san francisco how are you doing
i'm doing great michael thanks for
having me no no thank you for having me
and this is going to be a lot of fun and
i'm excited for these 20 minutes to talk
about
you know i.t and talk about consultancy
and talk about sentence which you're a
partner at and talk a bit about the way
that you work with companies to provide
some different thinking that they may
not have in-house and and especially
talking about you know today's world
where we have so many startups and so
many high-tech companies and the need
perhaps for an outsider to come and
provide this different level of thinking
and consultancy so before we get into
that leo tell me a little bit about
yourself and your own
path and journey which eventually land
led to you being a partner at sentence
awesome
so i'm from israel as you already know
was born into
a family
that worked for the government so
security was uh in my backbone uh ever
since i can remember myself uh security
was a part of it uh whether it was
intelligence privacy or secrecy
uh grew up in tel aviv so
very keen to see the environment
my career started though of course as
many of us in the israeli defense forces
where i was in intelligence units
helping create solutions for security
systems
won't be able to provide more details
but i assume you can think of what that
what that entitles to
my career started
in the us actually about 11 years ago
almost 12 when i moved to new york i
worked for private security
organizations overseeing enterprise
installations for fortune 500 companies
and many consulates and embassies uh we
did infrastructure security systems and
the majority was access control at
biometrics so that was a really fun and
paradigm time for me to see how the
world of security was from the typical
old burglar alarm systems into a full
video surveillance in closed circuits
whether if it's biometric or facial
recognition starting from 2d moving on
to 3d against spoofing
and that's where my career draws
and then decided uh to open sentence
with a lovely business partner uh to
provide uh
and disrupt the market of managed
services providers
uh we both have worked at other msps and
other startups prior to sentence and we
have seen a lot of things that's worked
and we have seen a whole lot of things
that didn't work so well
so we tried to take both realms and
combine them into a one-stop shop
for all of our cloud clients technology
and security and compliance needs i mean
what we call total i.t compliance and
security
obviously we'll go straight for the
interesting parts what doesn't work so
what have you noticed
across a pattern
that didn't work for tech companies
especially in your expertise in it
yep
the main thing that they didn't work i
think it was the complete approach to
the i.t and a managed services model
the older model was
based on a lot of legacy systems
so if you know if we're talking 10-15
years back the typical outsourcing it
model was let's bring on customers
charge them per user
put on them
our preferred softwares and applications
for us to be able to better monitoring
them and better support them basically
simply said being a value-added reseller
right
we believe that in this day and age
given that there is so many b2b sas
company and all of them are pay as you
go meaning you can go into their website
sign up for the services choose your
package and get going
we want to be the same
so we have completely moved away from
that model and coming from a model to be
a trusted advisor
we want our customers to feel that we're
just a part of their team that there is
no difference between if they hired
three or four people or if they hired my
company sent it
i think that's the biggest gap that we
needed to understand how to bridge
between really being there for our
clients internally
rather than being this outside
consultant
that pushing that pushes on them
products software hardware
and that doesn't have their best
interest in mind
right i think that's the biggest gap
what are the problems that companies may
face
so that they would need this assistance
and that you would be a good fit for
them what are those types of problems
we usually narrow them to three subjects
one of them is if the company does not
have an internal i.t
team
usually those companies are more
receptive of either a cto or director of
engineering head of people wearing those
hats for scalability for growth of the
team onboarding off-boarding or for
security and compliance
of course there are too many hats that a
single person can wear so that's kind of
our first entry to some companies
is to save the time which is the biggest
pain point for them they want to free up
their plate so they can focus on their
product and features which is more
important than focusing on their i.t
systems and just for clarification
because you know today you know i t can
mean for a lot of things so what
tangibly
would you be would you be would you be
specializing in the world of i.t within
within companies
so we would take their entire day-to-day
support and administration
meaning a common task that many of our
clients need our help with is onboarding
and off-boarding of their users is the
complete
a to z of of that topic so the
purchasing the provisioning of the
accounts whether if it's a new person
that got hired or whether if it's an
existing employee that got off-boarded
that's pretty much our number one task
the second task will be to help
customers achieve compliance
certifications for example suck
suck two compliance iso hipaa and to
stand in those regulatory um
so i think those are the two biggest
biggest pain points that companies will
come to us
and that will explore the possibility of
working with an outside vendor is to
free up the time so they can focus on
what they need to focus
and provide a posture
that is
fits the
this day and age security risks
and help their team scale
so
well though you're coming into a company
and you're
coming from the outside you have
expertise in the technology processes
organizational behavior
but you're coming into a new company
you're interacting with new people and
new cultures new leadership
what
share with me sort of the journey that
you're on
as let's say that i'm a new company that
comes to work with you what is sort of
the journey that you would have to go
through yourself
to come into my organization in a
healthy way and very efficiently and
quickly help me with the things that i
need help with
absolutely i think the number one most
important will be to understand the
company's pain point what's the reason
for needing an i.t i think before that
everything else is vague before
understanding the pain point of if it's
either free and up the time or needing
more support because they have
exponential growth or it's whether that
they have a security questionnaire that
their head of cells are blocked on that
they need to close the deal
those will be sort of types
that we will try to understand at our
very first conversations
so we can better
create a package that works for our
clients intention
when we start working with such clients
we perform what we call a discovery
phase the discovery phase is pretty much
our first handshake for example between
myself and you michael
during that time we understand the lay
of the land we get to see how things are
laid out how's the architecture looking
how's the infrastructure looking where
is the company currently at and where's
the company wants to go
you know a couple of years from today
because it's not only where you're at
now it's where you're trying to be sure
of course many startups as i don't need
to tell you they're trying to either get
acquired or become public whatever the
business decision may be at the end goal
we want to push them toward
that goal
so during the discovery phase it allows
us to understand the lay of the land so
when we actually start supporting a
client
we're very familiar
and very knowledgeable on their
environment to be able to make necessary
recommendation
to upscale their it poster their
security posture and be able to support
them on a day-to-day basis
right so it sounds to me that you're not
just
helping them with the things okay so i'm
coming and saying these are the it needs
that i have right now but you're
actually saying well that may be what
you have now but where
where do you want to get to
and because we know that you're going to
need abcd and you better start preparing
now and we could be we can help you
prepare for that even if you're not
there yet but this is what you're going
to need especially when we're talking to
liquidation events acquisitions mergers
and acquisitions etc
absolutely and
we have a big enough team with a lot of
different layers of experience to be
able to make those right decisions and
write recommendations not just from just
an it but i t security operations
we understand how all the teams interact
with each other at any given
organization
and we want to see what's their end goal
where are they trying to get to
now so a bit of outside about thing
thinking
what surprised you along the way as
you're working on this and as you're
meeting more and more clients and you're
working with companies what what is
non-trivial that that you're taking away
from this experience that you perhaps
didn't know before perhaps i couldn't
know without you having gone through
your experience myself
i think the first thing that comes to
mind when you've said it it was
there was a huge bridge
where smaller companies
and smaller founders as they're so busy
focusing on their product and features
time was not put into it into
consideration when it comes to security
and i.t and scalability of the team
because every startup as you well know
want to scale their team and grow
whether if they just got their seed
stage or whether if they got their
series a
they need to make a lot of hiring right
there's not a lot of thought process
because there isn't there wasn't a lot
of time to think about okay how can we
now bring on 30 more people or 50 more
people or 100 more people to our team
a lot of things will have to change and
there's a whole lot of new requests that
are going to come from those new hires
right so i think that's
one of the best examples to give
to your question
right now as you're working with these
companies do you usually find that you
have to
do a lot of explaining as to
you know where especially without if
we're talking about the greater scope of
what they make what their it needs maybe
down the line is it more focusing on on
their current needs their future needs
and how much of this is changing
consumer behavior from your perspective
that you feel that you need to do sort
of in educating the market versus being
the execution arm
so i think it changes between that
smaller companies and a larger company a
larger company of most of the time faced
with some of the obstacles so they know
the biggest players if it's for
provisioning or whatnot sure and they
know a little bit from hearing from
their other colleagues of what an
architecture should be
where smaller startups let's say just
got their precedent or just got their
seed
we see there is a lot of
miscommunication of what needs to be
done and there's a lot of education that
needs to be put in to explain okay
what are kind of the best of breed
things that an organization needs to
have in order to grow from an operation
and scalability and security
perspectives again
the smaller companies require more
trainings if it's security security
awareness training they require more
hand helding
through creating those processes
creating procedures where bigger
companies usually have at least a few
implemented procedures and processes or
policies
that we need to take and tweak
smaller companies we really created from
scratch
so that's the main differentiator in the
distinction between a smaller company
that just starting
off out of the garage per se to a
company that have has more than 50
employees that has been in business for
a few years and got the founders or
other people in the company have got to
experience some obstacles
right so having worked with
different clients
what is sort of a common thread
amongst startups and let's say you know
obviously some people that are watching
this are young entrepreneurs themselves
or early stage entrepreneurs thinking
through similar problems what are some
things that i as young entrepreneurs
should keep in mind as i'm thinking
through my own iot or security
frameworks within my own organization
already from the get-go things that i
may not be aware of but you can share
with me through your experiences
absolutely i think the number one most
important
will be security
i think early founders will be better
off thinking about security
earlier than later
because it does become a blocker
and the blocker becomes when for example
they try to do a poc for one of the
fortune 500 companies
and then they get a huge security
questionnaire that they have you know
they're having a hard time understanding
where to start right
i think early founders should put more
security budget more consciousness about
their security because it is a blocker
and also scaling the teams you know i
talked to a lot of early founders
from five people uh 10 people 12 13
and a lot of them
have the exact same question
hey we're about to get a new round of
funding how can we grow our team
fast with the least amount of resistance
well there's few options
to make sure that you can
i think those are conversations that i
do see a paradigm that early founders
are starting more and more to think
about
whether if we talked five six years ago
that wasn't the case
i think enough vcs now
do a good of enough job talking about it
as well
explaining the founders that that will
become a blocker
and thought should be put on those
budgets
uh so i think that's where the
distinction between again a smaller
company and a larger company that's
earlier founders security should be
taken in consideration because in the
end of the day
those are the sales that's what's
blocking from the company to grow 100
leo take me back a little bit in your
journey and i'm i'm curious you know
both what inspired you to go into this
into this world and say this is what you
want to do now but but even before that
go back to your childhood
free
you know back before sentence
where you know where does your curiosity
lie what really fascinates you in this
world
so there's two things that fascinate me
one of them was
geography my parents took me as a very
early age to belgium so i studied
international school of brussels
that's where i pride a lot of my
entrepreneurship skills as i needed to
meet people from all over the world
and be able to uh to adapt myself into a
new environment and make new friends
earlier than that i really had a passion
for technology because of course the
dot-com boom in their early 90s
thankfully both of my parents were in
technology so i got to see a lot of
hardware i would call it not yet the
software but the hardware one of my
earlier passages was
taking hardware components
if my parents would buy me a computer or
remember the first playstation
and literally taking it apart and
rebuilding it back together
nice to tell you most of the times i was
successful absolutely not
but that's where i started drawing my
passion into technology and into problem
solving how can i take something broken
and unbreak it
bring it back to its full self
i think that's something that really
stuck with me throughout my career and
throughout my life
is how can i take problems that i see
happening from a technology perspective
and find a creative solution
to them
that's i think the the majority of my
passion when it comes to technology and
so if you're looking today what you're
doing working with with clients and
working with your partner and
you know seeing a variety of different
problems in different companies where do
you
gather your inspiration in the
day-to-day
my the founders i work with
the the amazing companies founders vcs
that we work with
some people that we talk with are just
brilliant
and it is amazing to see some founders
passion into making this world a better
place
the excitement
that comes out of them about their
products and the things that they do or
passionate about that keeps my drive
going
uh
i love
one of
the best experiences that myself as a
founder of my company
have to go through is seeing a company
that we start working from a very small
stages being but or becoming public
i think that's a completion of all that
we stand for
of being a family and understanding when
is the time to let go and being proud
and honored that we were able to take
part of their journey from the garage to
exploding i think that's what keeps me
he keeps me going i love it
i love it and if there were a few words
that you would have to choose that you
would describe yourself
without asking anybody in your life
who's leo
what words would come to mind
think reliable
observant
and disciplined
reliable observant
thank you very very much uh it's it's
been a fantastic 20 minutes getting to
know you know this world and definitely
leaves me thinking about you know what
types of things i would need as a
founder and the way that i can leverage
the environment around me not just you
know do everything myself but think more
critically who are the right people that
could help me you know strategically
place myself in the future and
constantly figure out okay if this is
where i wanted to get what are some of
the requirements that would get me there
things that may be maybe not so trivial
and which goes back to the earlier part
of our conversation so little thank you
very very much
stay safe and stay healthy and best of
luck with the sentence and i can't wait
to keep in touch thank you
so thank you michael thanks for having
me and i really appreciate a great
conversation thank you